بعد فراق استمر لاكثر من ثلاثين عاما تمكن
المواطن السعودي تركي خالد السنيد بمساعده
سفاره بلاده في مصر من لقاء والدته
المصريه التي كانت قد انفصلت عن ابيه
وانقطعت اخبارها منذ ذلك الحين واوضح
السنيد انه افترق عن والدته قبل 32 عاما
حيث عادت امه الى بلادها دون ان يراها ولو
لمره واحده لم يتخلى السنيد عن حلمه بلقاء
والدته حيث سعى لذلك لسنوات طويله واخيرا
كان لقاء الذي انهى كل سنين الفراق
في الاول ان هو قالوا لي ان ابنك ابنك جه
ودور عليك فما كنتش مصدقه اكننا في حلم
يعني شعور فرحه مع ان انا مش مصدقه ده
فعلا الحقيقه يعني ده انا مش دي حقيقه
اللي بتحصل دي مش مصدقه لا انا شفت مراته
وبشكر وبشكر مراته بشكر وشفت ابنه شفتهم
يعني كده في التليفون انما ما قابلتهمش
وشعور يعني الحمد لله او بالبدايه ما كنت
مصدق هل انا هو حلم او انه صح او انه مو
بهذا الشيء لكن الحمد لله اني وصلت عن
طريق السفاره السعوديه
جهزوا كل شيء بالنسبه لي لهم فضل كبير بعد
الله للوصول الى الوالده انا كنت ابحث قبل
كنت ابحث قبل لكن ما قدرت اوصل يعني كلها
من كلام وكنت ابحث من عنده قاربي ما حد
وصلني لها فاضطريت اني اروح للسفاره فما
لي حل الا السفاره
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات